picked up by zigas who gallops to Center into the
Arizona Zone hands it off and a long shot off the
wing steered aside as Terry got it on net Ingram
with his first save now color no traffic and
it's in the equipment by kessle ring enables the
coyotes to cleanly exit the zone and it's kessle
ring who jumps up into the rush gets the pass from
Keller and Gibson hangs on to his bit Zach Sanford
for Arizona circles the Anaheim goal gets it back
to the point a right pass save made by Gibson on
the onetime shot and of course one of his career
lacrosse goals came against these Arizona Coyotes
that was in Arizona he's got it again through the
logo at Center stick handles right down the slot
and then his shot easily block ited away he tried
to hammer it in went off a stick and rolls slowly
in behind the Arizona net King fumbled it away
and Jones has it again on the near board peeds
the point fower left shot playing the right
side got the shot through melli pops out high
back for dery dery gets it back from Keller and
his one timer off the glass finds schals on the
puck recovery and now melli not able to handle it
50/50 Puck that the coyotes get back here's Keller
scores great pass by schz and the coyotes break
the ice why the Ducks thought they were going to
get possession three players tried to chase down
a puck on the near side boards and they could not
get to it in time just kept it alive and created
an outnumbered attack down low here's the play
I'm talking about boy that that's fortunate melli
goes off his leg bounces right to kerfoot kerfoot
for the OneTouch pass from schaltz and Clayton
Keller knows what he's trying to do with this
Puck elevate it get it up into the top corner he
picks the top Corner over over the glove of John
Gibson for a one- nothing lead valami across
the line and melli rolls it right into the
goal crease and a good reaction by Gibson coming
back to his left and we get a whistle the puck
played by a high stick the coyotes have only six
Road wins this season but that's just one shy of
their total from all of last year and here's
a turnover zooker in front and that off the
crossbar and on of play because they're turning it
over in dangerous areas of the ice Zer had Gibson
beaten High glove but you see he just hoists that
puck off the top of the crossbar and then over the
glass at the time by the Panthers as they were
moving Dave bolan's contract but he's sensing a
little bit of a theme here as lome gets one
through the coyotes have made some some Cy
trades over the years sometimes it takes a while
while and he's appearing tonight in his 22nd game
of the season from 34 games in that's number
one status contested there by leushin puck to
the corner and melli couldn't get his centering
pass through beg your pardon it was Krauss and
mnov leads the rush the other way coming late P
tono and that's gloved by Ingram including the
last four shots on goal in this game this is an
Arizona team that doesn't generate a lot from a
shot perspective they're 30th in the league
in shots on goal here's kie the former third
overall pick drops it back dery got it across and
not a lot on that shot as Gibson is able to move
to his left nice pass Jersey head up all the way
spots Jason zooker and it's another Point Blank
opportunity good sequence for the ducks in the
offensive zone but they still Trail one- nothing
melli hands it off to Krauss comes in Stick save
Gibson and the rebound taken below the goal line
by zis who got back Canadian Olympian just under
two years ago out of Austin College gets it down
low then goes back to the front of the net tries
to spin aama shot a little loose rebound to the
right of Gibson Sanford hacking away to Sanford
around the front of the netork Zach Sanford excuse
me and they get to a rebound and John Gibson is
there Gibson's been good again in this opening
period even though there's only been shots
there's been a lot of pucks directed his way
here in Period number one that was a good stop on
sford and zis beaten by mcpain on the draw carcone
gets it away off the board second leading goal
scorer this season Michael carcone for Arizona
he's got 14 on the season and he doesn't play
on either of their power play units he's got it
again from behind the net tries to wrap around
got to his own rebound Gibson held his ground
trying to poke it away and then reel it in and
cover and he does they're getting to those loose
pucks certainly not afraid to go to the front of
the net Carone with the wrap around and tries to
elevate that second opportunity John Gibson does
a good job there Melly gave stro a shot got the
puck back and then he's contested by vodan Nan
sends it down low buad on the wrap around and
a good stop by Gibson so just 15 seconds left in
the period Fowler engaged in a battle from behind
the night loses the puck schz goes far post
and Dumba hit the post they had the puck so
much Anaheim not doing a good job of protecting
pucks schtz wins a puck battle and then there's
always a cutter going to the front of the net
with this team in this case now it's speed for
Henri into the Arizona Zone trying to go wide on
kessle ring who finishes him in the corner but
the loose Puck kept alive mnov at the line back
for Henri to drags it around the defender took
it right into the goal nice pass from mikov but
Henri does a good job to pull it inside of kessle
ring across the line it's bu right through the
slot the col spun it right back on net trying to
keep the cycle going are the coyotes and now vodan
and knocked down by bad Dale comes over loses the
puck to machell melli picked up by Ross Johnston
snaps it across and they score some CR on the one
timer two nothing Arizona very similar to their
first goal it's winning Puck battles and that's
what's working for the coyotes see Nick buad
there just kind of lean on vodan and where's
he going going right to the front of the net and
that draws a lot of people towards him terver Zas
thought he was going to have to help out with
buat in front of the net and doing so just for
a split second he loses cool comes out High he'll
go in behind the net with it on his back hand pass
across Willam O'Brien hit the goal post again it's
another cross ice pass and a one-time it's wide
open in front of the net and then Liam O'Brien
it's his turn take a one timer and try to go up
top and now the penalty is over Ducks regain the
Zone silverberg hooks it right in front Qui blank
save by Ingram all over the ice to engage him he
didn't want any part of Ross here's a real good
play by silverberg and again Ryan Strow right
on the doorstep and good stop maybe the best
stopus melli all the way to the left wing half
wall and out to the corner brushes it back Jersy
the schmalz to popped out high pass across and
a good save by Gibson moving to his right as
he denied melli here's tonight's top tier play
brought to by Arco Clayton Keller on the power
play finds that scene boy the scam was wide
open open Matias melli thinks he's got the top
of the net and John Gibson makes a terrific save
watch where he gets this but just the very top
of the elbow enough to deflect it up and over time
coyotes were down to six minutes to go in the game
bami tries to glove it down over skated in andus
quickly over to vrono just enough of it for Ingram
Brett Leon has eight points in his last dozen
games drops it back and now this pass picked off
by dery who comes in close save John Gibson who
was well out on top has been really good in this
game micop wanted to give it to leushin but he was
going for a change then he changed his mind made
the wrong decision he'll send it around and in
Ingram will let it ride the kick plate Leon trying
to get it to the net and that will do it the Ducks
are shut out for the fourth time this season and
Conor Ingram has a league leading fourth shut
out of his own as the coyotes get the win